hello everybody my name is markiplier
and i have some very good news today
i finally have a sponsor
yes it's true epic games has sponsored
this video
therefore this video is brought to you
by epic games and i'm here to tell you
about my brand new creator code that you
can use with any purchase inside the
epic game
store markiplier m-a-r-k-i-p-l-i-e-r
anytime you use that code in the epic
game store it will support me
and make me feel good and also they will
pay me money
i'm not sure if i'm allowed to say that
but if this video goes up then they're
okay with me saying that
because that's the nature of the game
you use my creator code mark ipl ier
that's mark ipl ier you will be able to
support me
as a creator because it's my creator
code this video is brought to you by
epic games
did i mention that and this video is
about chivalry 2 which you can get
on the epic game store and if you get it
on the epic game store and use my
creator code
m-a-r-k-i-p-l-a-e-r m-a-r-k-i-p-l-i-e-r
then you will support me the creator so
this is chevrolet
chevrolet ii is an innovative game that
blends the fps in fighting game genres
as a result this is highly recommended
to complete basic training before going
online okay normally i'd skip the
tutorial because i'm a badass and i know
what i'm doing
but this time i'm gonna take it because
i remember playing chivalry one and i
remember being very bad at it
so i'm gonna try to not do that oh great
they sent me another future corpse to
try
you don't know that can you use the
angry
thingy what
this is my first day
i soiled myself and nobody cares
get them before they kill me go
[Music]
i soiled myself and nobody cares
can you read instructions never know
with
peasants who's talking to me is that you
up there you talking to me
oh shoot i've left this on
sorry if this sounded too epic for you
maybe it sounds good guys there's a lot
of things going on behind the scenes
right now that you don't need to worry
about but i'm a professional youtuber
who
definitely deserves to be sponsored
please don't take this away from me
i will cry i don't have any sponsors
besides you epic games
and i love you i love you
because you pay me money and you guys
use my creator code therefore i love you
um what am i doing i'm just going to
assume that everything is fine i'm going
to not assume that
everything is not fine one second now i
have officially changed back over to the
way
my audio is supposed to
anyway i'm gonna assume that
everything's fine because this is the
way i normally do it
f1 oh i'm not gonna remember any of
those okay battlecry emoji mode cancel
emo that's a lot of emote slots
got it right well then pick up that
sword and let's learn the basics
that's great against multiple opponents
that is easy come on
overheads deal great damage but are
harder to land
oh stops generally have the most range
yeah you're sharper than what i'll give
you that
no no obtain your tax in a combo to
overwhelm your opponent
this current mix up your strikes
you know what a swing is let's crunch
out some more of these logs
if these logs could kill you they would
[Laughter]
players retain control of their i'm
during attacks
so adjusting a weapons path mid-swing is
essential to learn
okay boss you got it i'm gonna do that
destroy each batch of logs with a
single attack okay into your swing i
break the attaboy i'm the best
smartphone yeah i'm the
try best kill them with your weapon
the first player to land a hit will
interrupt their opponent's attack
so turn to land your strike as fast as
possible
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
a combo after being blocked comboing
from being blocked
is a little slower it drains that
stamina quickly
my defending player is disarmed when
they run out of stamina
uh stamina use heavy attacks and
specials to smash down a predictable
defense
[Music]
oh
how do i keep this voice all the time
stun a blocking opponent
and then immediately follow up with a
strike
kick okay
hit your enemy by starting an attack
then immediately switch to a different
attack
uh-huh
[Music]
how are you getting all these other
people to be cannon fodder for me
because it's pretty impressive that what
i'm doing your opponents
wow turn the tip of your opponent's
weapon your crosshair not their chest
okay
you can hold block which rapidly drains
stamina and leaves you
vulnerable to a disarm
away from your opponent's attacks and
sometimes
yeah just gotta get out of his way let's
practice
darting
hey buddy stop
after a successful block there is a half
second window
to attack and perform over a post a
repost
okay i've always wondered how to
pronounce repost
oops that wasn't riposte
[Music]
well you don't know that you definitely
don't know that
enables a short counter window that will
deflect incoming strikes
of the same strike type counters act as
a perfect
pairing and avoid the stamina loss for
knock-back effects of normal blocks
listen you're throwing a lot of stuff at
me assuming that i'm actually going to
be good at this
which i don't think i will be but i'm
going to try my best
[Music]
earlier than you think
and timing is key now let's see if you
can recover
from taking a hit recovering you're
assuming i'm going to get hit
who's hitting who hi opponent has the
timing advantage
there are a few options to try and reset
but normal attacks
are not one of them okay follow me to
the waves of
jab dash blocker okay can interrupt your
opponent's combo
okay
well get your defense up quickly after
taking our hit
out of this one
each subclass has unique special items
which charge over time
and perform specific actions unique to
each class
like my ultimate you're talking about my
ultimate my ultimate ability
that's a good ultimate use your special
item
to finish him off what happens if i just
hold it
i'll throw it oh
that's kind of mean you know here we
come for a sword fight and then people
burn it okay
all right cool get yourself out before
we get back
do it um
okay what's the final challenge this one
hates throwing stuff
he's throwing some well that's cheating
projectiles but not those
shot by a boat how do you know you don't
know what i can do
to ensure you are prepared to defend
your honor
yeah hell yeah i'm i i think use emotes
battlecry use one of each modes emotes
all right role-playing dancing on the
battlefield
uh-huh oh hello hi
outnumbered is challenging you can block
as soon as you've landed a blow
a successful repose allows you to block
incoming strikes
for time okay
nice
apparently my life depends on it
wow
[Music]
oh got him
not to die today my pits i did it
i'm the first conscript not to die well
were they conscripts
which function which will it be the
ruthless mice in order
or the duties for agarthian knights
hearkens me back to the time when we did
that big
world warcraft thing i was leader of
team blue whatever that means so i'm
gonna go with blue
for the blue and gold i don't know why
what's with your eyes
and i probably should have gone with red
as the sky where the gods
guard over all never mind gold as the
sun
which giveth life with its sprawl yeah
indeed
the agatha knight stood and bled for
justice and the great war
yes they did but alas fell from glory
brought low by the traitorous mason
order oh a bunch of douchebags you say
for 20 years our land has strained
beneath the
boot of the masons yet the proud
old families of agatha do not forget
their former glory and pray for a leader
to ignite the flames of noble rebellion
in the name of argon ii we shall reclaim
the throne from the usurper
we will return a rightful rule to this
country of valor and benediction
once more the lion shall roar
or argon for the blue and
gold sure yeah okay
i'm willing to bet that the other
cinematic is kind of the opposite story
but saying that we're the bad guys
[Music]
in the battle of what what am i doing
i have no idea
ah man it's been a while since i played
chivalry i don't imagine that i'm gonna
do well
take it all in every last detail
your grandchildren will want to hear
everything about this day
for they will want to tell their
grandchildren
about the day you drove the traitorous
mason wamps
back into the dirt
apparently we're going forward all right
let's do this oh yeah oops
sorry hey wait one second oh
i think these are bots because they're a
little too easy
might be just a little too easy i'm
going for them
i'm screaming oh funkus
yonkos yonkos
yes please oh
oh i've been downed i was killed by
domino
yeah let's do that i like this game i
like it a lot i mean
there is something about like every game
that i've played in the past 20 years is
like
some form of a shooter having good melee
combat actually is pretty nice
i can tackle some i'm gonna tackle
someone i'm gonna tackle
well there's a lot of you yeah
take some of that oh yeah
and you're down and
wonkas yeah i got the range [ __ ] oh
wait hey watch it watch it buddy what
happened to my
uh throw i'm gonna tackle you oh
man they didn't want to hug all right
well here comes the legendary uh me
i think i must have thrown my halberd at
some point which probably wasn't the
best idea but it did feel good at the
time
oh that guy's very dead oh team damage
galunkas sorry bud
wow you can count good but yeah
right in the face
get some of this one of these
and what are these how about one of
these
your head's gone where'd it go
you're trying to stand back here you
coward
oh you're done
oh
apparently once they're on you you kind
of gotta fight him
i'm gonna tackle you nope i'm apparently
not going to tackle you
wow nope i'm actually blocking which is
an
interesting tactic
kick out
i'm gonna kill him i'm gonna kill him
got him i'm the best you know it seems
like a lot more than five remain
i'm just gonna say that
oh yeah oh god they're punching
you stupid fool take some oops
out my nog i'll throw this at you
but yeah
i mean that's pretty fun i'm not gonna
lie that's pretty fun
i'm not gonna lie those masons suck and
i'm amazing
those guys are awful and i'm the best
[Laughter]
now if i get up against real people i'm
gonna be terrible and then i'm gonna go
right back to the bots to make myself
feel good about myself
64 players 64 players mixed modes okay
what do we have
free for all team bubba the ball
oh i do not know yeah let's do 64 player
mix modes that sounds fun
i don't know how or why
but i'm going to give it a try and then
when i suck ass i'm going to go home
and play with robots and then i'll make
it seem like i'm playing against people
or lixian will hey lixian
you'll cover for me right you always
make me look good when i play games
i appreciate you uh he would never do
anything behind my back
i do i know what i'm spawn i'm uh i'm
spawning with a halberd
i like that i have not changed my voice
here we go
shunkas wow
oh i hit someone oh oh team hey i did
what the hell what do we do about this
hey stop that
you go nowhere funk yeah i missed
oh oh my god no you don't no you don't
oh sorry team i'm gonna throw oh i'm
down no don't do it don't do it
wow man these guys are uh kind of ouchy
i also don't even know what i am what am
i
i'm a footman i'll take it i'm a footman
that's a lot of convi
what are you giving us
this is like a delivery i'm charging
how did i miss that good you'll never
you'll
[Laughter]
oh yeah you never expected the knife i'm
taking him
oh what do i have i don't know what this
is it's pointy
what do i have what kind of jabber is
this
ah you'll never now you'll never
you'll never
look out i'll throw it
shunkas i'm taking it
i'm throwing it aha you've been got
i'm healing apparently i wish i had a
weapon of some kind
oh you'll never you'll never
oh sorry throwing it
taking it taking it up i'm taking it
i've taken it who healed me is there
medics in this how are you healing me
you ah yeah yeah oh nice
jumpers but you never expected the
thrown weapon
well or the sliced weapon
i am doing tremendously
ah yeah you'll never you can't and you
won't ow
thrown weapon i'm running away now
i have this what is it no no i put it
down though
this looks fun this guy's like some kind
of champion
and he's some kind of a dead
[Music]
you and some ow okay you would never
you would never
good thing i'm incredible they've kind
of been stopped dead here which is
pretty cool
we're winning i think we're winning
you'll never expect this
sorry i'm throwing it sorry
i hit my team again i'm sorry
all right so i'm uh uh taking this now
whatever oh it's a javelin it's a
juggling
oh yeah oh he blocked it i don't know
how
could i get a a weapon that's not a yes
it is
oh haha you never expected that
wow throwing shump
well how about some of the ah listen you
don't want to
ow you don't want to oh he wanted to
i'm gonna battle cry and then charge
oops oh
oh yeah can i get a spear
i like the sound of a spear spear sounds
pretty good
hey i'm not at bottom i'm flanking them
i'm gonna tackle you ah
[Music]
that much and one of these and uh some
of this
and then i'm gonna throw this at you
miss me
you didn't i did who are you get out of
here
one of these i'm talking now rubber
ugh
that's my that's my uh battle cry
i've got time for one last glorious
attack
one last charge into the deep here i go
i'm doing it what am i doing where am i
i did it hey i did it
i'm throwing it
did i get him this game is awesome
i'm gonna get out of that because i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go back to
uh the slaughter of coxal the slaughter
of a cox will
i just want to go to the slaughter of
coxel because i want to explore with
like different things
i mean i'm sure it would have been fine
if i would have just kept playing but
i just kind of want to dick around a
little bit but this game is very fun
hey sponsored by epic games but also you
can get this game for yourself through
the link in the description did you know
that
pretty cool right
[Music]
what are they just appear out of nowhere
oh interesting take some of this
okay well he's dead well these guys kind
of suck taken out by mere peasants
oh maybe not you'll never get one of
these
oh yeah riposte aye stop it
oh i've been down no please please have
mercy
have mercy well how about some of this
how can i get a spur where do i get a
spear
pull hammer spear ah level six i need to
get good
apparently i don't know if i actually
get any experience on bots
but kind of fun
oh yeah i'm coming
they're coming they're through the gates
you're gonna get some of this yeah
get eat my range he might range [ __ ]
wow
oh the range on this is much more than i
think it is
i don't even remember what all my
controls are uh kick throw special
special what's my special
i'm specialing oh no the special was a
bad idea
oh please no ow
man you guys kind of suck okay i'm gonna
try
change class we're gonna go bowman we're
gonna go
i will respawn what about right now i
guess i gotta go die then
time to be 100 reckless
here we go
what do you mean what did i do what did
i do
did i hit like an explody barrel or
something
you'll never get more people i hit them
kind of surprised oh god oh god they're
mad at me uh help
help
ow okay can i not defend it all as an
archer
ah sorry timmy uh
good god block my head is gone
man they do not like archers very much
they kind of come at me
bro but i'm the best and they all suck
so who is really the winner yeah oh i
can
hit apparently but i doubt this bow is
gonna withstand any kind of substantial
impact
take some of this oh take some uh
hold still hold stiller hold more still
good thank you are you a dude i think so
go blue team oops
oh sorry uh killed uh my dude
ah this is fine oh
well that's not good hey bud
oh yeah ammo i probably don't have
unlimited uh arrows do i
probably not all gone yama's all gone
oh
watch this epic you think you're gonna
get me you think you're gonna get me
take some of this
and this all right so uh archer's
interesting but
not nearly as fun i'm gonna say it right
now it's uh it's it's not as fun
what about vanguard what about
devastator i like the sound of
devastating things
that's fun i'm coming
apparently my voice is different i'm
devastating you
i'm devastating you you want to be
devastated
well your team doesn't like you very
much
[Music]
hey i'm pretty devastating
oh my god
oh wow miss me
you gotta kiss me man devastating is
pretty good
i like the devastation i mean again it's
just computers but the devastation
you can't argue with it i got a special
move here
i can also i also whoo hey uh teammates
maybe not go over there that
wow well do you do you i will hold this
gate and
none shall pass because i uh
throw i'm the best i'm the goddamn best
where'd it go where did where'd my axe
go this is it hey bud
you wanna come at me come at me where'd
you come from
i tried to dodge but it didn't work okay
all right okay all right my skull has
been exploded
i'm attacking sorry maybe i shouldn't
have attacked
man these sorry and these guys kind of
suck
maybe they shouldn't be just dumb butts
hey over here
wow oh my goodness
oh my god you're dead no way
i don't have any medicals
but i can scream so that's pretty cool
why don't you come through the gate
i was not prepared lopez
lopez lopez is the king of uh their team
hey uh how about some of this
how about some of this i'm the king of
my team i will throw it at somebody it's
you
teammate i missed throwing it
all right i'm blowing it more like it
oh yeah oh yeah
well there you have it i completely
crushed the bots
as i predicted and i feel good about
myself even though i won that game with
real people the bots are what really
matters because i crushed them
and they never stood a chance therefore
i am the best
that is chivalry 2. you can get this
game through the link in the description
below
at the epic game store because this
video is sponsored by epic games
that's right i have a sponsor in case
you somehow miss the beginning of this
video
and the sponsor is epic games so use my
creator code
m-a-r-k-i-p-l-i-e-r in the epic game
store to support me
whenever you purchase anything in the
epic game store link is in the
description to get show for a week too
check it out for yourselves i'm
sponsored
pretty cool right thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always
i will see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you